En qué punto está esta conversación que
divide al país sobre el acceso a las
armas
Exacto Muy buenas tardes Pues seguimos
de las mismas porque obviamente tenemos
una dificultad de conversar de convencer
a los republicanos A que pongan este
tipo de ley en camino no se hizo un
avance este año tuvimos algunas cosas
que se pudieron hacer pero más
importante que es ver cómo estas armas
no se puedan vender más que se eliminen
del mercado eso todavía nos falta tiempo
y no vemos que haya una luz clara que
nos va a llegar a poder hacer eso
mientras tanto vamos a tener como decías
continuamos teniendo Estos tipos de
masacres estas eventos horribles donde
los niños mayormente normalmente son las
víctimas de alguna forma estas personas
en se enseñan en lo que son las escuelas
los niños menores no y es en realidad
una tragedia en los Estados Unidos algo
que tenemos que resolver en algún
momento como usted misma lo decía parece
muy lejano el momento en que Estas armas
aparezcan del mercado cuál podría ser un
punto de consenso a corto plazo entre
demócratas y republicanos
una mayoría a bastante digamos una
mayoría que pueda llevar a cabo un voto
o sea eso representaría elegir más
demócratas al congreso y no vemos que
eso sea necesariamente algo que va a
suceder en noviembre Así que no no
tenemos muchas esperanzas rosas
desafortunadamente pero seguimos
trabajando constantemente para ver cómo
podemos lograr que Estas armas salgan de
las manos y específicamente de personas
que tengan dificultades mentales como
hemos visto con este pobre niño Cruz O
sea la combinación de los problemas
mentales con tener acceso a Estas armas
vemos las tragedias que hemos visto en
los últimos años y en relación a lo que
acaba de apuntar no A este chico Nicolás
Cruz que se ha considerado un sociópata
precisamente Más allá de unas
regulaciones sobre las armas como se
puede prevenir estos tiroteos masivos no
por como lo decía por un lado hay
personas que es un sociópatas también
hemos visto como en el caso de Búfalo
una motivación de una supremacista
blanco
en la Florida por lo menos tenemos
algunas leyes para proteger a los niños
a las escuelas tenemos mucha seguridad
tenemos todo tipo de protecciones que
hemos evitado aún aquí en el donde yo
vivo Miami esta semana un niño que llegó
una una pistola de 9 años a la escuela y
enseguida se descubrió y enseguida se
tomó acción en cuanto a eso o sea que no
tenemos incidentes de ese tipo acá en la
Florida en estos momentos porque hemos
implementado una cantidad de
regulaciones luego de parkland que nos
está ayudando a por lo menos mantener
evitar porque lo único que tú puedes
hacer es ver cómo previenes y Tenemos
muchos programas de prevención
identificar a los niños con problemas en
las escuelas para que no lleguen a
cometer este tipo de acto y rápidamente
para terminar qué opina de las
expectativas de ciertas personas
familiares de víctimas de parland que
esperaban que Nicolás Cruz fuera
condenado a muerte
muy desafortunado para ellos estamos
todavía en la televisión sigue hablando
con ellos todo el día no hay forma de
que un Jurado una vez que uno de los dos
te dice que no está de acuerdo la ley no
permite que se puede llevar a cabo la
sentencia por lo tanto hubo uno que no
estuvo de acuerdo y por lo tanto no
puede haber una pena de muerte porque la
ley no lo permite él va a estar
condenado a cadena perpetua